-Welcome back, everybody.
Seth Meyers is joining us here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congrats on the new book.
How is everything
on "Late Night"?
-It's great. As you know,
nothing like having
an audience back.
It's so much fun.
-It's the greatest.
-It's the best.
-All that energy.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But you're always --
I mean, when I first met you,
I know you did improv
in Amsterdam.
-Yep.
-And you know a live crowd.
You work off a live crowd,
but you became really good
at delivering jokes
with no audience.
-It was fun.
I don't know if you felt this,
but when nothing gets a laugh,
they kind of all get a laugh?
[ Laughter ]
It's impossible to bomb
when nothing's getting a laugh.
-Exactly right.
-They're all -- They're all --
-But no one can laugh, though.
Like, not even like Wally.
-Yeah.
-No camera operators.
-No, if someone --
If my wife accidentally laughed
in the background, I'd be like,
"Now you blew it."
-"Now you blew it."
[ Laughter ]
-"Now people know
these can be judged."
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly right, yeah.
I saw one of
your day-drinking segments,
which are so funny -- Rihanna.
And then you did one with Forte.
-Yeah.
-And I'm, like, "Oh, man."
-It was so --
I mean, you know Will.
You've worked with him as well.
It is so fun.
I already knew he was fun to
drink with, so there was no --
There was no stress about
"How is this going to turn out?"
-Of course not. Yeah.
-It was crazy
that it counted as work.
-Well, he's one of the funniest
people on Earth.
And you did something where you
dared him to make you break,
to make you laugh.
-Yeah.
-And this happened.
And the Internet really --
This is bizarre.
He got right in your face.
-Yeah, people pointed
something out.
[ Laughter ]
-That is your nose.
Can we zoom in even --
Your nose is bent in half.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you know your nose
could do that?
-I didn't know it could do that.
I think -- I saw that
and I think technically
I could fold it
into an origami swan.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, that's a talent.
-That's a talent.
-Yeah, not many people
can do that. Wow.
And did he -- He broke you, huh?
-He broke me.
-Of course he did.
-I mean, he is --
The thing about Forte was
never push him because his line
was farther than your line.
-Always.
You do a bit on the show also --
off the show, but it's online,
called "Corrections."
-"Corrections," yeah.
-Which is very --
I think it's a brilliant idea.
Did it start from some fan?
-Yeah. So, you know, via Twitter
and via YouTube comments,
especially during the pandemic,
YouTube comments were, you know,
a hurtful and helpful way
of finding out
how the show was going.
-That's correct.
-And there was this thing
I did by accident.
I said "Legos."
And you're not supposed
to say Legos.
The plural of Lego is Lego.
So you want to teach your kids
that so that that way,
when they say to other kids,
"Actually it's Lego,"
those kids will know
yours is an [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
And that will just save time
for everybody.
-That should be the next book.
[ Laughter ]
-No, but it's Lego,
or you can say Lego bricks.
-Ah. You can't say Legos.
-But it turns out there's a lot
of Lego fans out there
who were pretty upset about it.
And so over the course of
three shows,
I kept trying to
correct the correction
and I kept getting it wrong.
I said, "It's not --
You should say Lego.
It's Lego blocks."
And then they would say,
"Not Lego blocks, Lego bricks."
And I'm like, "It's Lego br--"
And then I realized,
oh, it's really fun --
the idea -- like, it sort of
takes the sting out of people
correcting you for tiny errors
if you address
every one of them.
So I do basically 15 minutes at
the end of each week on YouTube
where I just read through
YouTube comments.
And it's been actually
very informative.
I'm learning a lot of things.
-Really?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What's a favorite correction?
-So, for example, I heard
Benjamin Franklin's wife's name
is Deborah,
and I said "That's really funny
to me 'cause that doesn't
sound like a Revolutionary War
name."
Like Deborah -- I would've
assumed the first Deborah
was born in like 1961. Anyway.
Then people said, "Actually no,
Deborah is a name in the Bible."
And I said, "That's shocking.
That would be like
if you heard, like,
there was a Candace
in the Bible."
And then they were like,
"There's a Candace
in the Bible."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Yeah. So when you do
corrections, you just realize
you're never going to get
everything right
and that gives you the freedom
to continue
getting things wrong.
-Wow.
I wonder if people will find
something that you said tonight.
-Oh, I'm sure they will. I
secretly buried seven mistakes.
[ Laughter ]
-That's why he's a genius.
Seth Meyers, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congrats on the baby,
and congrats on the new book.
Seth Meyers --
"I'm Not Scared, You're Scared"
is available now
wherever books are sold.
And "Late Night" airs weeknights
on NBC right after us.